sao paulo en brasil y la capital
mexicana ciudad de méxico son dos urbes
situadas en américa latina' la región
con mayor cantidad de agua del mundo
aunque ambas podrían quedarse sin el
valioso líquido en 2015 los embalses de
reservas de agua para sao paulo y otras
62 ciudades de brasil se quedaron a un
4% de su capacidad y afectaron a 15
millones de personas toda una paradoja
en un país que posee más del 12 por
ciento de las reservas de agua del
planeta en ciudad de mexico
1 de cada 5 habitantes tiene acceso a
agua potable tan solo unas horas al día
las cañerías de la urbe de 25 millones
de habitantes filtran el 40 por ciento
de agua de la ciudad la misma cantidad
que ciudad de mexico tiene que importar
para funcionar el problema del acceso al
agua potable se extiende por la región
américa latina' a pesar de contar con el
31 por ciento del total global del agua
dulce del mundo tiene una gran
desigualdad de acceso mientras que en
uruguay el 96% de la población puede
acceder a este recurso sólo el 46% puede
hacerlo en bolivia una cifra que se
acentúa en el 24 por ciento en haití
las regiones a la vez una de las más
castigadas por el cambio climático lo
que la convierte en vulnerable ante una
eventual crisis de suministro de agua
además el banco mundial alerta que la
escasez de agua por descongelamiento de
glaciares y de la acción humana como la
contaminación de cuencas hídricas y el
impacto de la agricultura en la región
perjudicará ampliamente la seguridad
alimentaria de sus habitantes
actualmente en el mundo 2200 millones de
personas viven sin acceso a agua potable
según naciones unidas que indica que
para 2030 la demanda mundial de agua
dulce aumentará en un 40% respecto a los
índices de 2015 para evitarlo el banco
mundial llama a mejorar los sistemas de
almacenamiento y asegurar una
distribución responsable del recurso